[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here at the University in Berlin
students are hard at work prepping for
the exams meanwhile students and
Budapest are busy fighting for the
survival of their university the CEU or
Central European University which may be
forced to leave the country and the D
hashtag I spent with Cu hunger issues
are leading the charge for academic
freedom and democracy
I imagine this scenario that see you
moved to another country I guess
devastated and that's why I decided that
that I would blame myself if I didn't do
anything
[Music]
eighty thousand people would have come
for one universities it came for what
the removal of PU represents it
represents an undemocratic societies
which represents the politics of peers
it represents that you know anyone could
be the next target
[Music]
it's a platform for discussions between
conservative liberal leftist which is
not really happening in other
universities because of the whole
political climate that that's happening
is set up by the government in the last
seven years
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people are devastated that 27
years after the priests don't change
this is what's going on this is really
freaking me out
where we are heading now
we've also decided to take a legal
action on the higher education law
[Music]